every Central Claim about the 2020
election made by failed former president
Donald Trump and the people around him
including people like Mark Meadows but
also wackier people like Sydney Powell
Mike pillow Lindell and others every
single one of those claims was
systematically contradicted and debunked
by mostly Republican testimony as we saw
during yesterday's second day of the
Trump Riot hearings I'm going to give
you some examples here and you will see
how comprehensively every single one of
these claims is easily easily easily uh
refuted former Philadelphia City
Commissioner Al Schmidt a republican
said there is no evidence of even eight
dead people voting never mind the 8 000
dead voters that Trump and people around
him claimed in the claim that dead
people were voting in fact Mr Giuliani
told Pennsylvania state legislators that
eight thousand dead people voted in
Pennsylvania you investigated those
claims of voter fraud can you tell us
what you found
Not only was there not evidence of 8 000
dead voters voting in Pennsylvania there
wasn't evidence of eight
we took seriously every case that was
referred to us no matter how Fantastical
no matter how it served and took every
one of those seriously including these
so it's not that they say well every you
have to investigate all of it it was
investigated you just don't like the
outcome of that investigation and we've
so dead voters that's one bucket of
claims we've looked into it extensively
uh there was an investigation I believe
it was in Michigan where they started
with a list of suppose I believe it was
ten thousand supposedly dead voters
um and again I now and I I believe it
was the guardian if not the BBC they
said let's randomly choose
um I think it was 35 of the Thousand or
to 2000 whatever let's investigate them
and then with those 35 they found most
of them there was evidence that the
people were alive like there was just
really no reason to think that they were
dead in a few cases it was people who
were indeed alive at the time that they
voted and then they when they mailed in
their ballot then they died nothing
illegal there in some cases there was
like junior senior confusion I mean it
was all it was all just picked apart and
next claim
um Georgia smuggled ballots former
acting Deputy attorney general
testifies that he personally
investigated the Georgia smuggled
ballots found nothing told him it was
false but it didn't matter we'll play
again
a testimony from Mr Donahue who appeared
before the committee before today
Mr Donahue you we talked it some liked
about whether or not the White House or
the president was informed about the
Antrim report
on the results of the investigations the
interviews that have gone on on Fulton
County
um how would those results have been
communicated to the White House to the
president
I don't know how they were initially
communicated I do know that they came up
in subsequent conversations with the
president and Dad Rose and I essentially
told him we looked into that and it's
just not true
okay so he wasn't he was informed
I told the president myself that several
times in several conversations that
these allegations about ballots being
smuggled in in the suitcase and run
through the machine several times it was
not true that we looked at we looked at
the video we interviewed the witnesses
it was not true right we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines so there is another claim the
idea of ballots smuggled in and there
were videos with ominous music of
suitcases in different places with no
reason whatsoever to believe that the
suitcases contained fraudulent ballots
people left suitcases it's not like a
huge The Smoking Gun in and of itself
and Trump was told and yet he continued
to repeat it and then lastly again just
as another example we could do this all
day but I won't do it to you the other
claim was more votes than voters in
Philadelphia Philadelphia and
Pennsylvania in general became a big
Focus because they stopped counting and
then started again of course if you
understand the scheduling for vote
counting in Philadelphia you would know
that they just have a schedule they stop
counting and then they start again the
next morning not really evidence of
anything but the other claim was more
votes than voters and William Barr
Trump's own attorney general says it's
not true there were not more votes than
voters and anybody just Googling
Philadelphia Pennsylvania population
would be able to realize that I'd like
to turn to president Trump's false
allegations about election Integrity in
Philadelphia the Attorney General
discussed these allegations at some
length
you know the idea the president has
repeatedly suggested that there was some
kind of outpouring of unexpected votes
in inner city areas like Philadelphia as
recently as January 13th when he walked
off the NPR set
he was asked by the interviewer and
what's you know what's your evidence of
Fraud and he said more people voted in
Philadelphia than there were voters
and that was absolutely rubbish the
turnout in Philadelphia was in line with
the state's turnout and in fact it was
not as as impressive as many uh Suburban
counties and uh there was nothing uh
strange about the Philadelphia turnout
it wasn't like there was all these
unexpected votes that came out in
Philadelphia so right you know I think
once you actually look at the votes and
then
there's an obvious explanation he you
know for example in Pennsylvania Trump
ran weaker than the Republican ticket
generally he ran weaker than two of the
state
uh can anyway the point is William Barr
knows that it was all BS so every single
one of these claims what do we know
about them we know two important things
one there was not actually any evidence
for them but maybe even more importantly
too there were Republicans around Trump
who knew the claims were BS and would
tell Trump that they were BS and it did
not matter so a very critical moment in
yesterday's Trump Riot hearings one of
our sponsors is Magic spoon the only
breakfast cereal that tastes exactly
like your favorite sugary childhood
cereals but with zero sugar only four
net carbs and 14 grams of protein so if
you're just generally trying to keep
your sugar intake relatively low like me
or if you're doing low carb if you're
doing keto you can enjoy the sweet
nostalgic snack without the sugar in
flavors like cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter cookies and cream Maple waffle
blueberry cinnamon they've just added
Honey Nut to their permanent collection
I love magic spoon our whole team does
and they've been supporting the show for
years how about this if you try magic
spoon and you don't think it's amazing
like we do they'll give you your money
back because magic spoon stands behind
their product because it's that good you
really can't tell it apart from the
classic cereals build your own custom
variety pack you'll get five dollars off
when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman and
use the promo code Pacman the link is in
the description